let f be a differentiable function for
all x if f of negative 2 is equal to 3
and f prime of x is less than or equal
to 7 for all x
then what is the largest possible value
of f of 10 and so i encourage you
to think about this on your own pause
the video try to figure out the largest
possible value for f of 10 and then
we'll work through it together
so i'm assuming you've given a go at it
so let's let's visualize this
so let me draw some axes here so let's
say that's my x-axis
that's my x-axis right over there and
this right over here is my y-axis
that's my y-axis or i'll graph
y equals f of x and they tell us f of
negative two is equal to three
so let's say that this right over and
the two axes aren't going to be drawn to
scale so let's say that this is negative
two and this right over here is the
point negative two comma three
and they tell us that f prime of x is
less than or equal to seven that the
instantaneous slope is always
less than or equal to seven so let's
let's so really the the way to get the
largest possible value of f we don't
have to necessarily invoke the mean
value theorem although the mean value
theorem will help us know for sure
is to say well look the largest possible
value of f is if we essentially of f of
10 is essentially if we max this thing
out if we assume that the instantaneous
rate of change just stays at the ceiling
right at seven so if we assumed that our
function the fastest growing function
here would be a line that has a slope
exactly equal to seven
so
a slope of seven
would look
and obviously i'm not drawing this to
scale this
visually this looks more like a slope of
1 but we'll just assume this is a slope
of 7 because it's not at the same
this is not they're not the x and y are
not the same scale so slope
is equal to
7. and so if our slope is equal to 7
where do we get to
when x is equal to 10
when x is equal to 10 which is right
over here
well what's our change in x
so what's our change in x let's just
think about it this way our change in y
over change in x
is going to is going to be what
well our change in y is going to be f of
minus f of 2 f of 2 is 3
so minus 3
over our change in x our change in x is
10 minus negative 2.
10 minus negative 2
is going to be equal to 7. this is the
way to max out our what our what
what our value of f of 10 might be
if we did if at any point the slope were
anything less than that because remember
it can never be the this instantaneous
rate of change can never be more than
that so if we start off even a little
bit lower
then the best we can do
is get to that
we remember we can't we can't do
something like that that would get us
too steep so it has to be like that we
could and then we would get to a lower
we would get to a lower f 10 or if we
did if we did some every time you you
have a slight a slightly lower rate of
change then it kind of
limits what happens to you so remember
our slope can never be more
our slope can never be more than seven
so this part should be parallel so this
should be parallel to that right over
there this should be parallel you can
never have a higher slope than that so
the way to max it out is to actually
have a slope of 7 and so what is f of 10
going to be
so let's see 10 minus negative 2 that is
12. multiply both sides by 12 you get
84. so f of 10
minus 3 is going to be equal to
84 or f of 10
is going to be equal to 87. so if you
have a slope of 7 if you have a slope of
7 the whole way you travel 12 that means
you're going to increase by 84. if you
start at 3 you increase by 84 you're
going to get to 87.